[Music]
all right okay which brings us i don't
even know if we should really be doing
this on this show but uh oh that's fun
we have actually uh a wonderful uh
artist here smooth manny the colombian
who um has been here on the show in the
past and he actually went to school and
studied art he's a wonderful painter and
uh he's actually he moonlights as a
police sketch artist and so now it's
time for smooth manny the police catch
artist
[Music]
all right smooth manny is here we'll
need him to adjust them and quarter
black gear is going to go over there and
turn off the monitor so that smooth
manny can not see okay uh the picture
um so smooth manny tell people a little
bit for people who don't know we've done
this before you went to school for art i
did hold on a second we can't hear him
get his mic there up there let me see
can we hear you hey okay here we go you
went to school for what uh it was a
bachelor of fine arts oh and i started
computer animation but i learned art
along the way isn't that bachelor's
whatever i think so there's it is an s
so you know he's foreign
he's going for a fine art bachelor might
be added hey wait yeah that's true
you're you're foreign so you're okay
with our uh sheila jackson league bit
right yeah okay good there you go we're
fine as long as the guy who looks white
doesn't mind yes yeah
oh my god you really don't want any job
security do you dave
he's just like going out on top baby
and you moonlight as a police sketch
artist uh yes i this is my side job this
is your side job and it's a lucrative
career
you know nowadays there's security
camera footage right so i always
wondered that you know like if if if
christopher walken you know was out of
work that there are no more dead zones
you know i mean they're not necessarily
they don't need the psychic and the
gazebo to figure it out when you've got
simply safe they're just lining up like
can i help no we've got cameras right
um so we are going to describe for you
uh a recent uh uh criminal uh an outline
criminal and you are going to sketch it
for us uh i don't even know why we do
this
why not okay just so you can see the
process you know every now and then uh
so let's show for people watching we're
gonna be taking your chat here at mug
club but this is the person
that's that's okay i am seeing that for
the first time wow that is uh who i hear
you know what dave come over here should
i see this yeah yeah come over here no
there's just just here so you can see it
because you can just really quickly hold
it up so that dave landau can come
around and see
what i have to get manny manny to draw
wonderful
so i'm going to start with the circle
yeah well you know what um it's a it's a
little more um
angular
what do you mean angular i mean some
people have you know um like oval faces
and some people have more chiseled
features and some people have really
chiseled
almost as though they were actually
placed there with a chisel
yes
so it chiseled like a very manly jaw or
like i wouldn't say that no no
no no not man cheekbones i would say
angular definitely i mean a defined jaw
right maybe a a bell pepper nose that
was chiseled down to nothing
yes roughly yes so very angular so yes a
sharp line this person is very thin okay
yeah i was gonna say like a jaw like
jocko's or more thin no more thin more
thin angular a little like less a little
less jocko a little more gerard de pardo
i don't know who that is or snidely
whiplash little snidely whiplash are you
drawing iron man or dudley do right okay
so uh i would say this so uh very uh god
what about the
very great features
yeah is almost not one so it's a very
it's a very thin very thin very small
thin nose like picture someone who had a
nose maybe a nose job who had too many
and then it got too small like someone
who might need this to hit the high
notes
i got to say getting pretty close yeah
he's actually not that far off
okay what about the eyes big small
uh squinty
lifeless
so i would say
lifeless until
uh
a child might walk into the room but i
don't think this picture was yeah i
don't think taken at this point so right
now it's that of disappointment but
they're i would say they're kind of
they're not super around a little almond
shaped you know kind of like like when a
dog is happy
you know the guy's eyes aren't
okay and a red button-down shirt like
corey feldman might wear right yeah okay
like a fedora like corey feldman white
might wear and a a red button-down shirt
a black fedora and coming out is kind of
uh the man has long hair it's it's kind
of a mullet but it's longer in the front
than i would say like a soul glow like a
soul bone yeah yeah so like us
a cherry curl yeah
not a not like a surfer
kind of
oh i don't think the joints would be
able to handle it no no
all right so you describe the
i mean i'm not going to draw the hat but
maybe you're saying curly hair kind of
curly wavy hair curly like not like like
tight curls but you know it's black hair
that is somewhat curly think like an 80s
sort of uh kind of 80s rock and roll
yeah not a surfer but might wrestle like
hit on a water bed yeah yeah right yeah
yeah just you might just want to curl up
with some hot cocoa and um go through
home alone one through seven and their
parents are staying six miles away at
the nearest hotel yeah what about uh
eyebrows
you know like uh
well they're artificial
yeah artificial artificial eyebrows so
there are they're they're thin and
angular thin and angular again
everything is very angular everything is
very sharp this person keeps in shape
but sharply methamphetamine like angry
shorts
yes yes that's good yeah yeah you are
getting very very very close not so much
in shape as has enough pills in them to
not be able to eat food or keep it down
yeah that's true really to not and not
require it no really and that really not
required it's not whatsoever i would
almost describe this perp as a marvel of
science
very much so yeah
they're smiling because if it is who i
think it is there is a kid in the room
right now
really are you are you putting a kid in
the room
no that's uh i would not incriminate
myself okay
yourself no yeah of course
yeah you might come into the house
with the parents to get a settlement
i think some parents asked for that up
front yeah they did there's but then but
then do the right thing when hbo comes
calling and the statute of limitations
yes right right right that's often when
one has their come to jesus moment
that's true true yes it's got to be
michael jackson yeah but for some reason
you drew it as a scooby-doo villain
you were closer to michael jackson
before you knew it was michael jackson
something about the lips i i always i
always remember him with this really
weird butt chin that just looked
like the nail plastic surgeon
that's also what he would convince the
kids was his uh
butt
yeah he also
just it's just my chin
i don't think so yeah who knows the
difference like start like like the
haunted house when you turn off the
lights and you tell the kid that the
meatballs are eyes
yeah it's like it it's
so bad but it's a change what's the [ __ ]
it's the fun of riding a ferris wheel
when you can't sit down
oh yeah all right
all right let's finish this up
with the lips it's gonna be something
yeah let me let's finish up the lips
here because yeah and you know what
here's the good thing is this man is a
well-known criminal yes he is alleged
[Music]
homosexual pedophile rapist michael
jackson
jesus staring at the boy is that what he
got canned for isn't that right yeah he
they said victoria's don't make fun of
oj
or michael jackson so he got a
homosexual pedophile and then made a
joke where he just called out yeah he
just called him a murderer and that's
why he got fired i love it i want to see
the original drafts of michael jackson's
songs because it's all about like loving
women and you know yeah you know it's
just like you really don't matter if
you're six or five i know right there's
like an editor like no no no no no no no
no no we have to adapt this
oh thank you thank you so much uh uh uh
paul anka thank you could you just go
ahead and change all the boys to women
yes i don't have the time and change all
the change all the creepy stuff where
i'm committing felonies to just you know
cuddly okay all right we'll do that you
want some jesus juice i do not want no
no no no no
dissolved in red wine in a diet coke can
but i believe there's a six-year-old who
does oh
macaulay must be here
he just wants me to go on tour with them
just fly around the world and don't
don't touch the chimpanzee he was
expensive but he is pissed he will bite
he will did you ever know about that
chimpanzee was like an animal in
captivity hyperly aggressive it was the
same you know it was the old navy chimp
in connecticut that they gunned down in
the driveway that was michael's no it
wasn't it was a different one it was the
old navy one though that would sit in
the car on the commercials oh really
yeah and then she got it and was like
you know what chimps like wine and
they had a fight over the remote yes
we'll know somebody was like here's a
banana cake and then it ripped her face
off
it's pretty tough when you go from a
fine burgundy it's true banana cake's
just not gonna do it she had the first
face transplant and boy did it look like
the first
[Laughter]
all right let's see michael jackson
let's see this here you got it right you
guessed it's like guess who only
incriminating thank you very much smooth
manny this has been smooth man the
police catch artists
[Music]
i thought this was a fun show got off to
a rough start yeah
garrett hey you know youtube's fault
okay let's go to some chat i feel like
you should say chat with the walking
voice i think it would just fit it's
time
it's called chat
it's much better save that that's the
intro
chat can i turn this smoke parliaments
i don't okay
i kept them i kept a pack of cigarettes
up my ass
and i found out
that's not what it's for yeah turn out
turns out it's your chin
um i don't know why we're talking
i have no idea why did you say the word
chat and i'm like it just should be in
the walk-in voice it does sound walking
it's better
chat yeah there you go it's just it
sounds fun okay do we need a stinger now
no i don't think we need to we should we
need to do this
for some reason i went into i don't know
why i always makes token left but in the
morning when i call him like at five in
the morning i just do that i say hey
buddy
jack black buddy you're working on the
show buddy you're the best and it's not
the drugs talking buddy it's not the
drugs you're not on the phone it's
uncanny it's
am i talking to jack life i've never
heard steven's like how do i soften a 5
a.m phone call
checking up on you
that was really no i'm impressed though
for real you know what i
used to um i used to have a bit about a
celebrity cruise ship going down with
different and uh it was uh johnny boy's
favorite bit and i just always felt like
it was such a because like you always
feel like with impressions in stand-up
it's so hard to fit it in yeah like hey
what would it seem like if uh robert
neal were cutting a zucchini
yeah an awful rich little setup yeah oh
my god no he does a fantastic nixon
oh yeah i like that it's time to get me
a 50 cal yeah
i remember yeah i thought this is dudley
moore at nixon's office you're like what
is this what year am i in the stand yeah
he's not even doing deadly movies like i
am
wow this is horrible i actually got
here's the worst part i got bumped for
rich little what where it's sean
hannity's freedom tour ah well you
dodged a bullet there it seems
that whole sentence
who said that i didn't resonate with the
audience
oh you were funny
i've taken a lot of hits in my bag
oh no
how soul crushing that is at 23. you're
like i'm sorry who yeah is there another
one well frank travolino wasn't
available so
sorry we went rich little
who else was after him corpse of milton
berley
okay so i was close i'm sorry henny
youngman uh is not going to be able to
bring you on the gutval tour
[Laughter]
by the way do you have a line of contact
for phyllis diller is she
yeah she's still up in spry yes we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out don't
worry call your people all right let's
go to chat all right zone palmer has an
easy question for you why shoulder carry
um you know what actually i just do it
because it's comfortable to carry here
in the office so i carry it in the
office around my house and it started
with we were going to do an open carry
walk
uh in austin yeah
and we didn't end up doing it because
that was the garrett foster thing
remember and everyone wanted to kill
right oh yeah people were trying to kill
us in the city of austin so we had to
get the hell out of dodge and all of the
hobos yes it got together
yeah it's hard to differentiate the
hobos it is very hard it is that's just
they just get a bunch of hobos to yell
out i am antifa
and then you don't know
um but uh i always want to do an open
because i do i will say this
my goal with this
show what i do obviously it's to be
entertaining it's it's it's an
entertainment show but as it relates to
my point of view as it relates to my
beliefs my conservatism right my world
view um i want to have as i want to
create as many other disciples
christians conservatives good men good
women happy people as humanly possible
right i want to make it as accessible as
humanly possible and so i feel like with
firearms you often have
either the open carry people who go out
there with the most and there's nothing
wrong with this by the way i'm not i
have no problem with these people it is
their right and i understand the value
in it but i think that we only have kind
of two groups of people people who go
out with the intimidating plate carriers
the ar-15s or the ak-47s and their ski
goggles and they say it's my right and
it is their right and then you have
people who are really afraid of it and
so i said i want to go and do an open
carry but i want to do an open carry
walk the way i would want most people to
open carry and that would be you know
something on your hip so some of us had
hip holsters and i said you know i'll
put on a shoulder holster because for
some reason i don't know why uh you add
some leather and steel and it's less
intimidating to people than like a black
polymer gun because people don't know
they assume black polymer is scary it's
a 50 cal so it started with that and
then i realized it was just really
comfortable and when i came home i mean
my wife just what she would i mean she
was she was a demon
i think this is really the answer this
is really yeah
and if i come home and if my wife isn't
there and i put my firearm on my desk
i do it louder
[Applause]
that's like treats with joe lewis and
this is my wife she just comes she just
comes calling absolutely no that's a big
part of it i just we wanted to do and we
will do that eventually i want more
people and i want more americans to be
in a good way desensitized to open
caring i want americans to when i lived
in michigan live in a town where a lot
of people open carried yeah um because a
lot of them were hunters too
and it's not a big deal but you never
see those people they're not open
carrying with plate carriers and ar-15s
yeah they're walking around a lot of
them will have long guns but you see a
lot of people with revolvers on their
hip especially if they're going out
hunting and maybe it's like bear season
so um that's why that's really all it is
is i want it to be visible and i want it
to not be scary you look like a
detective in like a 1960s movie no no
the role i play
don't want to hear these things
sometimes i'm going to get really kinked
oh no no no no no
first class seat
and you have to earn it back
all right another chat my wife is not
happy about no not at all this one's
from gwen roberts hey crowder just
signed up for mug club my boyfriend
thinks it's it's us against the
politicians instead of red against left
what are your thoughts uh no
i find this funny because this often
comes from people who are like oh man
they wanna they just wanna keep you
sheep and that's why they use these
broad
broad generalizations like right versus
left and then i just go people versus
politicians well look what gives you a
more accurate snapshot
of what someone believes if they
identify as conservative
or if they identify as liberal or if
they happen to be a politician or not
they're great there are some great
politicians who we agree with on a whole
lot and i understand that the system
corrupts you know i understand that
obviously a lot of people look out for
their own self-interest but i i i i
don't understand this people i don't
want to put label we put labels on
things all the time and i don't want to
hide from one look i'm conservative i've
already taken the hits for it i was
talking with dave about this yesterday
um you know unfortunately conservatives
were talking about rich little they
never really appreciated comedy and
entertainment so i was a little bit of a
redheaded stepchild there and then a lot
of comedians never really understood how
unsafe it has always been to have
right-wing views in the entertainment
industry they would always say as long
as you're visited right
but they would just say as long as
you're as long as it's funny i go no
that's not true no no managers wouldn't
even represent you in some cases i had
my agents dropped me yeah had my agents
dropped me um and i got into trouble uh
i would be this is in 2005 and 2006 i
had clubs that so they wouldn't book me
yeah anymore and it wasn't even it
wasn't even dirty so anyway my point is
no it's not us versus politicians you
really just do if you're going you're
always going to have to make some kind
of a label that's why labels exist
you're always going to have to make some
generalizations to make a judgment call
so you should make them based on values
based on principles and lining people up
that way rather than their job because
then you end up with kind of class
warfare where business owners are all
bad look i don't think everyone who
works on wall street is bad i don't
think that they need to pay astronomical
taxes i just think they need to be held
with the same rules as every other
american that's my world view so if
someone understands and agrees with that
worldview and happens to work in finance
i consider him an ally if he happens to
be a politician i consider him an ally
if the politician believes that i should
have to pay an 800 insurance fee and my
address should be publicly posted to
antifa just because i own a walther well
then it's me against that first class
seat stealing politician
succinct there you go another one more
chat and thank you for joining mug club
by the way thank you so much by the way
yeah and i understand what your husband
is saying and i i or your boyfriend is
saying i understand that look it does
feel like the deck is stacked against
you and i i there is validity to being
disappointed in republicans politicians
across the board
they're mostly useless yes all right
final check they get a good one there
token okay i got a good one for you
andrew breitbart's birthday was this
week and bob loblaw wants to know what
do you think he would say to you about
current events if he was still alive you
know what i posted something about that
on instagram we were just talking about
this yesterday you asked me if i uh i
think you asked me if i knew andrew yeah
because well i obviously saw the sign
and righteous singing uh indignation was
one of the first books that i read from
a conservative author right what did you
think of the book i loved it yeah pretty
i mean this is before the cancel culture
thing was or social justice warrior was
a term but andrew kind of knew how to
identify the the leftist culture well
and i related a lot to him as when he
was young right and he kind of explains
the progression of just himself and just
going from a kid with a certain forced
ideology to starting to see a different
picture and he really does explain it
beautifully all the way to working for
the huffington post i mean everything
that he put in there is it's a really
good read for anybody yeah and um
i mean i've talked about this before but
not only did i know andre i mean andrew
was the first person to rsvp
at uh my wedding that's what you said
yes he was actually the answer i got he
was looking into property in western
michigan oh really uh because he said he
said it's this is the first place for my
kids for some really there are lakes in
california but not i didn't know what
this was and they put down their phone
it's like this wonderland like he just
he loved it and i told him he was gonna
love it um and he loves the people there
in western michigan but i will tell you
this i wouldn't be doing any of this if
if not for andrew breitbart andrew
breitbart was
an accidental it was just sort of an
incidental lifeline what happened was um
i had i think at this point yeah you
know i had been doing acting and stand
up since i had been very young and um i
just done some films and i didn't get
paid a whole lot and uh at this point
the there wasn't really a lot of work we
were after pilot season and my parents
said you uh okay well you better have to
you better get a job then at this point
i didn't want to wait tables and i said
you know what look here's what i'm going
to do i have enough money from the last
thing that i've filmed
uh i'm going to do youtube now
and i'm going to treat it like a
full-time job
do it for six months i have enough
runway for six months it turned out that
then i didn't need it after three months
i knew that i could that i could do it
um and i messaged people this is back
when youtube had direct messages i would
message people there were no
conservative channels but i would find
channels that were like pro firearm
channels or i would find channels that
were former military channels and say
like hey you might like my content and i
got to 10 000 subscribers so i was
treating it like a full-time job because
i realized that i didn't play well with
others in the entertainment industry
i've told the story i was on a show
called greek where we got into it over
south park and the guy did not like me
the director
um the abc family show
yes seriously yeah i had what's funny is
i had a character if you go on imdb
called jace it was supposed to have a
multi-episode arc and it could have just
it could have been named drunken drunken
frat guy number two right because
they called and complained
immediately afterwards and i know it was
because of a very specific conversation
we had about south park and liberals
because the guy was a fan of south park
and i thought he was one of uh us and he
wasn't the irony was lost on him yeah he
doesn't get south park no he doesn't get
south park uh and he thought i didn't
get south park and that turned into
something even more hostile he's not
gonna like trey's views no he is not so
what happened was um i heard andrew
breitbart on dennis miller's show and i
was listening back before really podcast
i would tune in to a uh uh i knew there
was a station in texas because i didn't
stand up at the cap city comedy club and
so i knew that dennis miller was on the
station so i would listen to dennis
miller almost every day as radio show
and i heard andrew breitbart on the show
and this was before it was breitbart the
trademark it was uh he couldn't get the
the website breitbart or
bighollywood.com the reason his name was
included
was because he wanted to get
bighollywood.com andrew's first project
he was talking about this
on dennis miller's show was big
hollywood he had to get the url
breitbart.bighollywood.com because big
hollywood was already owned and someone
was sitting on it and it was a place for
conservatives
in hollywood to speak and then it kind
of turned into bloggers who were
conservative to write about hollywood
but the first writers there obviously i
remember ben shapiro there's a guy named
gary eaton john nolte um
they were only a handful uh adam baldwin
and i heard andrew breitbart on dennis
miller's show and it was just for me
kind of like you with his book i said
this guy well this is that's that's what
he's saying that's what i am you know i
had not really heard many people like
that before right and so i found his
info and i called him and he treated me
like i was the head the senior booker
for bill o'reilly he spoke with me for
45 minutes oh wow he hung up and i sent
him a stand-up reel and then he called
back and he said like yeah he said yeah
well i know i see it and i understand
what you're doing is kind of touchy the
hey kind of cholo voice i don't know
andrew i'm just showing you them a
standard kind that's not i don't want to
post this to the website well i already
posted it
okay and i said no i wanted to write for
the site and then i will say i kind of
forced his hand i started doing these
youtube videos and what i just did was i
said to the editor there i said look hey
here's what i'm going to do at the end
of the youtube video i'm going to put
big hollywood up there as a credit and
that way i kind of promote you you kind
of promote me and you know and they were
like you don't have to do it like i
already did it so post the video and so
it sort of forced them to support me but
it became popular and then at that point
michelle malkin started posting things
at hot air and because of that i had
enough that back then 15 000 views on
youtube was a ton yeah and um then that
took me to a company pj tv where i
actually met my wife and that took me to
fox news uh for four and a half years
and um yeah i never actually worked for
or with
andrew i just worked alongside i was
always just i would just contribute
whenever whenever uh i felt like it was
an open door we were friends we were
colleagues and he was incredibly
supportive and i remember him having a
conversation one time with me about
doing my due diligence before storming
kind of storming the castle and he
really understood what leftism was
because he lived
in that uh world you know he was from
los angeles so he had his finger to the
pulse of it and he didn't hate anybody
that was also something too people talk
about happy warrior i watched andrew and
look andrew obviously made some mistakes
and him and i had our differences but
andrew really believed in what he did
and andrew changed the media landscape
forever i'm gonna talk about bright part
the trademark i'm talking about andrew
breitbart the man yeah and it was an
uphill struggle it was an uphill
struggle not a lot of he was persona non
grotto there at fox news when bill
o'reilly screwed the pooch at one point
bill o'reilly edited the shirley sherrod
tape out of context and then when she
got fired blamed andrew breitbart but
andrew breitbart uploaded the shirley
charade tape
where she said something racist in the
tape and people clapped and then later
on she said i learned that it was racist
and that it shouldn't be about black
versus white uh so andrew repper wrote
this article this is this is a sign and
let me know if this is making sense here
but this is something that was a really
rough period in andrew breitbart's life
and it really went a long way this was a
formative for me to see someone redeem
himself between these years
leading up to anthony weiner so he did
the acorn stuff he won some lawsuits he
had built his website up he became
persona non-grata and i watched everyone
turn their back on him including people
who had gotten their jobs at fox news
because of andrew breitbart and i got my
job indirectly as a contributor because
of andrew breitbart because he put my
name in okay so i owe him a lot and a
lot of other people owed him a lot they
turned their backs on him and
that for me
made me kind of okay
mark some folks all right i understand
you wouldn't have what you have without
andrew breitbart and now you threw him
under the bus for optics he didn't you
didn't even think he was wrong here's
what happened andrew breitbart had a
video i remember shirley sherrod you
might be able to find it she was head
she was a black lady head of uh some
kind of agricultural department this is
years ago so she was giving a speech to
the naacp
andrew breitbart uploaded this post to i
think this was big government at this
point big government.com
and uh again it was before it was
breitbart it was just big government.com
and it's her saying i did not help the
white farmer as much as i would help the
black farmer and the naacp audience
and andrew breitbart in the post at big
government in this post and now if you
fast forward to whatever it is 27
minutes in she does
talk about how she learned the lesson
that it wasn't about white versus black
it was about helping those in need and
her humanity did eventually get the best
of her but that doesn't change the
audience reaction when she said
something racist right his focus was the
naacp clapping at racism before they
hear the redemption yeah it's being like
people clapping at ebenezer scrooge
saying are there no prisons are there no
poor houses before you watch the third
act andrew breitbart was very clear
about that bill o'reilly runs the video
on his show one of his editors cuts it
just at that part no context and says
and shirley sherrod basically saying
that she's a racist i don't know why
she's still allowed to have a job she
gets fired because of the outrage
unbelievable and then liberals say why
you're taking out of context look she
said that her humanity got the best of
her and it wasn't about racism and bill
o'reilly goes on air and a lot of people
fox news and they go this kind of gotcha
journalism is just as disgusting to us
from the right as when the left does it
and andrew breitbart you should know
better he did know better he posted it
these people weren't willing to take
responsibility or but for the fact that
they wanted a sexier story and they took
the con they took the quote out of
context and so he became persona non
grata he wasn't on fox news for years
yeah and people who had jobs because of
him didn't throw out a life didn't
support him and i remember he was going
through a pretty rough grind because he
knew he was right and he knew that they
knew he was right and at that point what
happened everyone would use it as a verb
they would say oh breitbart it was a lie
it was a lie but it's oh a breitbart got
your journalism breitbart to the point
where when anthony weiner this happened
right all these i think it was a couple
of years then the anthony weiner saga
happens andrew breitbart at this point
says i have these naked pictures from
anthony weiner right these stories have
been going out what does the media do
the media goes oh yeah you're going to
believe you're going to believe this
anthony weiner because they were
planning on him running for office they
said it was false they said the story
wasn't true andrew bright but and even
alec baldwin said this has a whiff of
breitbart about it i remember him
tweeting that so he tried to turn it
into a verb to discredit andrew and
there were complicit people at fox news
on the right to the point where andrew
said look look i have the pictures from
anthony i have the pictures from anthony
weiner i'd rather not release them as to
not destroy his family publicly but you
have to stop
raking my name through the mud i
remember him saying and they kept saying
lies lies lies anthony weiner anthony
weiner was holding a press conference i
think it was at the omni i don't
remember it was there it was on c-span
and he was about to go out there
publicly with all of his sycophants in
the press just like you see today no
accountability and say this is a smear
campaign from andrew breitbart and
everyone would go
of course breitbart and dismiss it these
pieces were already pre-written and
approved this is what was going to
happen and someone yelled out through
the hallways andrew breitbart's in the
building you can read about it it is
bone chilling and he went up on that
podium and said i have the pictures
and if immediately anthony weiner does
not apologize and acknowledge the smear
campaign and the attacks on my character
i will release them i would rather not
release them and anthony weiner crumpled
up his script and went out and admitted
fault and apologized but i watched
andrew breitbart have all of his friends
turn their back not all of them but a
lot of them turn their backs on him for
political expediency and for optics and
that was important for me to watch it
was important for me to see that triumph
because then everyone wanted to be
andrew's friend and that came with a
whole bunch of other problems sometimes
where you know your star rises too
quickly and and i wish that he would
have been able to take care of himself
better but andrew breitbart was someone
who it's not just some it's not just
something i put on my resume because
i've never put it on my resume he was a
man who um
had a really significant impact
on my life and he's had a more
significant impact on all of your lives
thanks for watching i know i totally
ruined it
you said more of a impact on everyone's
lives out there than you probably even
know and so i would recommend you you
read his book right his indignation um
if you can and uh what i love about him
is he's just listen he's not perfect
he's he was a he was a character he was
he's lost in some ways trying to do the
right thing and uh loved people really
loved people and and did a lot of good
so andrew i miss him and uh
what do you think about today
listen i think you could probably guess
it wouldn't be that hard
andrew was an open book what do you
think andrew andrew breitbart lived to
burn down the media establishment i do
think that andrew breitbart if he were
alive would be in a very different
situation with big tech
i think that andrew bright will be one
of the few people out there who would
actually be filing lawsuits like we are
and actually trying to hold politicians
accountable rather than lip service and
trying to maintain their own platforms i
think andrew breitbart probably would
have been a lot more and i would like to
think you know i talk about this
sometimes i'd like to think that he'd be
proud of what i built but i don't know
you never know
doesn't matter there's still a lot of
things that he did right that that i
want to emulate and even some things
that i don't want to emulate but
that that was that was formative for me
seeing him
be [ __ ] on
be betrayed people turn their backs on
him and uh and seeing him win because in
real life the good guy doesn't always
get doesn't always get ahead doesn't
always win and he did hey this is the
part where i would say if you like this
video subscribe hit the notification
bell or comment down below but none of
that really matters because you probably
can't so just bookmark this page check
it every day with a live show monday
through thursday at 10 a.m eastern
because nothing else works
and everything in 2021 is awful and that
right dave yep